[Music]
[Lynn Corwin:] I, I had a lovely time, Hal.
[Hal Grover:] Yeah, sure. I'm glad you did.
You're, you're all right. Oh look, it's late.
[Lynn Corwin:] Will I see you tomorrow?
[Hal Grover:] No, not tomorrow.
Some of us fellows are going to the drag races
over the weekend.
But I'll call you sometime when I get back.
[Lynn Corwin:] Fine. I'll be waiting.
[Hal Grover:] Well, I'll be seeing you.
[Music]
[Mrs. Corwin:] Lynn?
[Lynn Corwin:] Yes, Mother?
[Mrs. Corwin:] Oh, I guess I must have dozed
off.
I was just going to rest my eyes for a minute.
What time is it?
[Lynn Corwin:] Oh, it's just a little after
11:00.
[Mrs. Corwin:] You're home early.
Everything go all right?
[Lynn Corwin:] Oh, perfect!
I still can't believe it.
Mom, he took me to the country club.
Imagine me, dancing at the country club with
Hal Grover.
I, I wish you could have been there, Mom.
They even had a combo.
Thanks, Mom.
Thanks for making me this dress.
I know you should have spent the time sewing
for your customers,
but the dress was exactly right.
I didn't feel a bit out of place.
[Mrs. Corwin:] Well, when I sew for Hal's
mother and her friends,
I see the kind of dresses they wear, and I
just --
[Lynn Corwin:] I know Hal was impressed.
And I think that's why he took me to the country
club.
He wanted to show me off.
He likes me, Mother.
I just know he likes me a lot.
[Mrs. Corwin:] Well then dear, what the dress cost was worth it.
[Music]
[Narrator:] Unfortunately, the final cost
of the dress
has not been calculated.
The price that Lynn Corwin must pay will be
a high one.
[Mrs. Corwin:] Going up to bed now, dear?
[Inaudible].
[Music]
[Narrator:] The dress, like many other things
in today's world,
is part of an enormous subtle pressure which
our times put upon young people.
Evidence of the pressure is plentiful almost
anywhere you go.
Evidence of the worship of sex appeal,
as if it were the final essence of personality.
[Drumming and music]
Who is to blame if young people respond to
this pressure,
reenacting in the privacy of parked cars
a theme hurled at them from every side?
Who is to blame if they respond to what
an anxiety-ridden world seems to be telling
them?
"Dance faster, little children."
[Music and singing]
The lyrics in the shadowy room may be suggestive.
But at that they suggest something more human
than most of the headlines around the spinning
globe.
[Music and singing]
Faster. Faster. Faster. Faster! Race to live
while you may.
[Music]
And a part of the frenzy to experience,
to learn about everything,
takes Hal Grover and his friends to another
part of the state
to participate in the weekend meeting of drag
racers
from all over the area.
[Music and sounds of car engines and tires]
But drag racing is not the only amusement
a city has to offer.
[Music and singing]
[Hal's friend:] Ah, how much longer are they
gonna be?
You'd think Hal could find some other place
besides our room.
Man, I'm tired.
I want to go to bed.
[Hal's other friend:] Hal and his women.
Oh, finally!
[Friend:] Yeah. Hey, check that out.
Come on, give up lady.
[Other friend:] Still? He never quits.
[Music and singing]
[Friend:] Well, don't you even have to take
her back where you found her?
[Hal Grover:] Ah, she doesn't live far.
Besides, she has to go home alone.
Her parents are the strict kind.
They don't allow her to go out with boys.
[Laughter]
[Other friend:] So she can go home and tell
them about meeting a new girlfriend...Hally?
[Laughter]
[Music and singing]
[Dr. Jamison:] When I turned up the third
case
of primary syphilis in ten days,
I knew Oakdale was up against it.
I don't mind saying I was amazed.
I've been out of medical school for 15 years,
and haven't seen a handful of cases.
And now, three of them in ten days.
And I'm not the only doctor in town reporting
cases.
It looks like a real outbreak.
[Man at desk:] Well, that's for sure.
And from the reports you and the other doctors
have sent us,
one that's pretty well confined to kids from
12 to 19 years old.
What's more, it's too big for a health department
this size
to handle on our own.
That's one reason we've asked for assistance
from the state health department.
They're sending us John Camp,
who is especially trained for this work.
Mrs. Elliott has been interviewing the patients
you and the other doctors have sent us.
But she can only do so much.
A public health nurse has a lot of other duties.
[John Camp:] Hello.
[Man at desk:] Well hi, John. We were just talking about you.
You know Mrs. Elliott.
This is Dr. Jamison, President of the County
Medical Society.
Doctor, this is John Camp.
He's field representative from the venereal
disease program.
[Dr. Jamison:] Mr. Camp, we have a lot of
work to do.
[Narrator:] Every doctor in Oakdale has a
lot of work to do, including Dr. Sam Holdeen.
Dr. Sam, to those patients who have known
him for many years.
[Miss Day:] Won't you step in, Lynn.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Why, hello, Lynn.
I'm glad to see you.
Since we got you through the tonsillitis stage,
I haven't had much chance to keep acquainted.
[Lynn Corwin:] Oh, I don't think I'm really
sick now, Dr. Sam.
But this stuff is a nuisance, and I'd just
as soon be rid of it.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] All right, let's find out about this stuff.
[Lynn Corwin:] Well, it's a breaking-out.
I tried to hide it with makeup,
but it's all over me.
Mother thought it might be the three-day measles,
but I may have had them.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Well, let me call the nurse.
and we'll check you over.
Miss Day, would you come in, please?
[Lynn Corwin:] Thanks a lot, Edna.
Well, Dr. Sam, what do you think it is?
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Could be a number of things.
Maybe an allergy to some food.
I'm writing you a prescription that may help.
You use this for a couple of days,
and let me know if there's no change.
[Lynn Corwin:] Okay, I will.
I feel better already,
now that there's something I can do about
it.
Well, bye.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Oh goodbye, Lynn.
Give my regards to your mother.
[Music]
It could be an allergic reaction.
That rash isn't entirely atypical.
[Narrator:] It looks like syphilis.
[Dr. Sam]: Lynn Corwin?
It couldn't be!
[Narrator:] Now hold on, Sam.
You're a doctor.
You know VD doesn't play favorites.
Just because you brought that girl into the
world
and have taken care of her all of her life
doesn't make her immune.
Why didn't you take a blood test?
[Dr. Sam:] Because it just couldn't be!
[Narrator:] As doctors are human,
so there may be in their hearts the wish
that some things just couldn't be.
But as doctors are men of science,
dedicated to the welfare of all their fellow
beings,
that wish must give way to a review of the
facts.
And the facts leave no room for wishful thinking.
In the long years of his practice,
Dr. Sam has too often seen the final tragedy
of latent untreated syphilis.
He has seen those whose minds were destroyed,
whose bodies were horribly crippled.
And he has seen helpless babies born of syphilitic
mothers,
the most tragic victims of all.
What Dr. Sam knows only too well
wipes out every trace of his momentary wish
that
such things couldn't be, where Lynn Corwin
is concerned.
Especially with Lynn Corwin,
one of his children, such things must not
be.
Syphilis can be cured, and if, regrettably,
Lynn has syphilis, she must be cured.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Lynn, this is Dr. Sam.
I think maybe you better...
[Narrator:] As Lynn Corwin makes an appointment
with Dr. Sam,
other doctors have sent in young people whose
disease
has already been diagnosed.
Appointments with John Camp, the field representative.
John Camp's job is not an easy one.
Nobody wants to hear what he must tell those
he interviews.
And nobody wants to tell him what he must
find out.
For syphilis can be halted only if everyone
involved
is located and examined.
With the approval of their personal physicians,
John Camp interviews every patient diagnosed
as having syphilis,
to learn the names of all those
with whom the patient has had sexual intercourse.
[John Camp:] I appreciate your bringing your
daughter down, Mr. Nedrick.
The interview is confidential though,
so if you'll just take a seat in the hall.
[Mr. Nedrick:] Yeah, I'll have a seat in the
hall.
I just brought her in to see if you could
get it out of her.
I can't find out what kind of trash she's
been running with.
[John Camp:] Please take a seat in the hall,
Mr. Nedrick.
[Mr. Nedrick:] Oh, I'm leaving. You're welcome
to her.
She's no daughter of mine.
[Music, and soft sobbing]
[Narrator:] The parents of teenagers who have
blundered blindly into infection
are sometimes more blind than the children
they condemn.
John Camp is all too familiar with typical
parental reactions.
[A mother:] It's that sex education they get
in the schools.
If my boy hadn't known about such filthy things,
he wouldn't have got curious, and he wouldn't
be sick.
I didn't want him to find out.
Not me nor his daddy told him nothing.
But some other busybodies did.
[A father:] Oh, I'm surprised all right,
but only that he had the guts to do it.
He's the biggest pantywaist I ever saw.
[Laughter]
But I sowed my wild oats when I was a boy but...
But I didn't think that kid of mine had it
in him.
[Laughter]
Hey look, I'm not gonna preach at him.
It's the church's job to preach.
[Woman sitting next to her husband:] My husband
and I will both tell you
it's not Junior's fault.
[A second mother:] It's all his fault.
I just can't do a thing with him anymore.
[Music]
[Narrator:] Confronted with those who have
been judged,
who come to him even under the best of circumstances,
ashamed and afraid,
John Camp acts neither as judge nor prosecutor.
He is an investigator dealing with the facts.
[John Camp:] No, you didn't get syphilis from
the toilet seat, Bill.
You got it from sexual intercourse with somebody
who had it.
Now, these are the people that we have to
talk about,
for their protection as well as for yours.
[Narrator:] Nobody wants to talk.
But because John Camp sees beyond the patient
to the welfare of the whole community,
he must make these youngsters realize their
responsibility.
[John Camp:] All right, Bill.
Now, what about your very best girl?
[Bill:] She's, there isn't any--I haven't
got a best girl.
[John Camp:] You wouldn't want to walk out
of this room
with somebody's life in your hands would you,
Bill?
[Bill:] I...No, but she's all right.
[John Camp:] Bill, that's something a doctor
has to decide.
Now, her name is?
[Bill:] Her name's Betty.
[Teen:] Her name is Mary.
[Teen 2:] His name is Jack.
[Teen 3:] Her name is Susan.
[Teen 4:] Roberta.
[Teen 5:] Bob.
[Teen 6:] JoAnn.
[Narrator:] The names are many, and there
is usually more than one,
for the patient must tell the names of all
sexual contacts
within the infectious period.
if the chain of infection is to be broken.
What makes John Camp's job more difficult,
and increases the danger to the community,
is the fact that there is sometimes no name
at all.
[John Camp:] All right, Tom, who else?
[Tom:] Nobody.
Just them.
Just them and some girl at the ballpark.
I didn't even catch her name.
[John Camp:] Where does she live?
[Tom:] Who knows, it was a night game.
We never got out of the park.
[John Camp:] Well, tell me what she looked
like,
anything you can remember about her.
[Tom:] Oh, she was just a pickup.
[John Camp:] She may be the reason you're
sitting where you are now.
[Tom:] If she is, I wish I'd never laid eyes
on her.
She really gave me the come-on,
and her a foot taller than me.
Uh, she had sort of light blonde hair.
[Cheering]
[Narrator:] Starting with a known hangout,
the ballpark,
with only a vague description of a girl.
The field representative tries to find one
of the known contacts of an infected person,
and here, as with all other cases in Oakdale,
he is successful in locating a potential source
of syphilis,
the tall, aggressive blonde.
Unfortunately for other communities,
a number of contacts are named in surrounding
towns.
Locating a possibly infected boyfriend in
Ashton may be simple.
Since Ashton is across a state line,
another state health department is alerted,
to find the boyfriend.
Another field representative continues the search,
perhaps finding that in our increasingly mobile society,
a search has become more complicated.
The job of this field representative now becomes one
of knocking on doors in the last known neighborhood.
Seeking clues.
Asking.
Continuing to ask.
Until he finds someone who knows where the
Farleys
or the Hagans
or the Smiths have moved.
To California.
To New Hampshire.
To Mexico.
The Oakdale outbreak has spread its tentacles
nationwide,
crossed an international boundary.
It is not and has not been from the beginning
Oakdale's problem alone.
Syphilis is not only an individual problem,
but a community problem as well, as Hal Grover's
father is finding out.
[Ed Grover:] I always thought you were a good
doctor.
But now I'm going to find out if there's any
legal action
that I can take.
It looks to me like you're violating medical
ethics.
What a doctor treats a patient for is nobody
else's business.
But you had to call in the whole health department,
subjecting a boy to that kind of questioning.
[Dr. Jamison:] Ed, those interviews are confidential.
If you know what the boy was asked, it's because
he told you.
As for me,
I was following good medical practice and
obeying the law.
VD has to be reported to the health department.
Protection of the public is more important
than the temporary embarrassment to your boy.
[Ed Grover:] Him embarrassed?
His mother is sick with mortification,
and I can't stand to look my friends in the
eyes,
whether they know what's happened or not.
But he's not embarrassed.
I told him I didn't even want to claim him
for a son.
You know what he said?
He looked at me as bold as brass,
and he said...you never did.
I bought that boy everything in the world
he ever asked for.
Bicycles.
Ponies.
Car.
He's got the best clothes...
and the biggest allowance in town.
What more can he want?
[Dr. Jamison:] I don't know.
Maybe he wants the thing
he seems to have been looking for pretty desperately,
somebody who cares.
[Mrs. Corwin:] I wasn't worried when she was
out with him.
He came from one of the best families in town.
[Mr. Corwin:] If it just wouldn't make it
harder for Lynn,
I'd haul Hal Grover out in the town square
and beat him within an inch of his life.
[Dr. Sam Holdeen:] Well, that might be the
least of his troubles.
I believe Lynn,
and I think you do, too.
When she says he was the only one.
[Lynn Corwin:] It isn't all Hal's fault.
I could have...
Oh, if I'd just stopped to think.
But I wanted him to like me.
Mom said she wasn't worried when I was out
with him,
but I was the one she couldn't trust.
I was the one.
[Mrs. Corwin:] No. No, honey...
[Narrator:] Lynn is more fortunate than some,
to have parents who will make the difficult
effort to understand.
With Dr. Sam's help, Lynn Corwin will be cured
of the physical disease,
although she may never be free of its emotional
consequences.
The 50 or more young people who are victims
of the Oakdale outbreak
will all be cured.
Either in the clinic of their health department
or by their personal physicians.
The outbreak in Oakdale will be over.
The local health department's file marked closed.
Somewhere, in a city where a drag race was held
is one who was forgotten.
Whose name, if it was ever known, was not
reported.
Is this your town?
Is this your daughter?
Is this your son?
[Music and singing]
Dance on, little children.